a quick little update on on dayton
hypernova that we played yesterday the
gentleman who uh
who says he gets beat up by his brother
sherman all the time
i received the comment on the video that
we clipped from a
a the username is a chuck schultz and i
confirmed it
he is their uncle and he goes yeah
they're both terrible and they both
should be kicked out of the house
uh for those who don't know watch the
video but uh dayton hypernova is a
gentleman who
who's 32 years old he lives with his
parents and his older brother
uh and he says that his brother beats
him daily
uh so here's here's another video we put
a new video up and then there's this one
uh this one is titled i get beat
stop denying
okay so you just heard my older brother
that looks like a that looks like a
reasonable
uh he really does did you see somebody
in the comments corrected us
last night in the comments of our video
about this guy no because i was like
yeah what is he he looks like
and i said uh randy rhodes or whatever
and i was like oh i don't know he was
dark hair and i said zack wilde and
somebody's like you're an idiot
zack wilde has dark hair too that's and
then he said some other like the guy
from rat or something
people are just naming you like 80s
guitarists it's just really funny
okay so you just all right look there's
no
i got these scars i was gonna say the
crow reboots looking terrible okay
because it looks like he looks like he's
doing joker lipstick
hey can somebody make sure they use the
same blanks that brandon used during his
crow movie
thanks i used to have a brother and he
would beat me
all the time at the outback steakhouse
you know how i got these scars when i
was eating a bloomin onion and outbreak
and my brother he was really crazy
[Laughter]
brother going off at a computer screen
dance
they're just in his room whoa hold that
let's listen to that slurred speech here
real quick folks hey guys
i like pills going off at a computer
screen dance
they're just in his room he just walked
downstairs
this is the man i live in the same house
as
he [ __ ] beats me
that's [ __ ] horrible
this is not acceptable behavior he has
been
look at his eyes okay hold on smile
though your heart is breaking
smile you know what's going to happen
right
theta kings is going to grab this video
and he's going to make that
no look this is just so bad
you're good at knowing what people are
wrong he's drinking but what else this
is not just but i used to think my life
was a tragedy
and then i realized that well yeah it's
pretty much a tragedy
horrible it's terrible what do you think
he's on
by his speech and everything just
everything he found
probably benzo probably like some kind
of benzos but also some kind of
uh you know delicious opiates maybe
we call them delicious they are
delicious well they don't mean to taste
wild
man who beating me
down repeatedly since
forever ago it's been five years of him
beating me down this house i have
psoriasis are you talking about batman
yes
never start with the head it beats me in
interrogation rooms
[Laughter]
where are they just beating the [ __ ] out
of his brother
is not that visible right now because
it's the middle of summer
it bleeds into the winter and it's
caused by stress
oh and he said he just come back from
watching the rocky horror picture show
i don't know if you missed that he's
coming back up he's kind of he hides
and then here hold on let's not we got
right around
here
i just came back from rocky horror
picture show
from pinky
my older brother beats me when he sees
me
it's weird how you seem to have a lot of
videos
a lot of videos of you talking about a
lot
but talking about the beatings you never
seem to be able to capture any of these
beatings on tape
no if they happen well yeah he does when
he hit his brother
no what i'm talking about yeah just
these on these completely unprovoked
beatings right
you would think if they happened so
often that you would easily catch him in
the act
but well let me let me read something to
you because like i said in one of the
one of the comments
of the video uh from charles
schultz which i'm not doxxing anybody
because that's his youtube name
his uh hero and this guy's name is earl
schultz he says it in his video no one's
being
uh chuck schultz this is so disturbing
this is this is so disturbing
i feel so bad for my uncle and my aunt
yes i am related to these two clowns
both should be kicked out of the house
years ago earl has had a job
uh earl has never had a job
for him time to be a big boy or girl and
get kicked out of the house then he then
they email me charles schultz
emails me his nephew i believe his
cousin emails me he goes
i don't think would be good for my dad
to be on your show he has seen a few of
these crazy youtube posts and he's very
close to his brother so i can
uh i can't do your show but my sister uh
is going to email you she lived close to
him for years i've been living in
florida most of my life
so we may be getting some people that
could shed some light
on this relationship yeah we got an
email too that was uh
pretty in-depth i don't know if you read
it it was we had an email from i must
admit at revenge of assist.com yeah i
was telling you up uh
where you get another show i was like oh
did you see the email i thought you were
talking about the comments email
i was talking we got an email bro
we got an email i don't remember if it's
from that chuck guy but it's from
somebody else in the old
family there um
oh yeah oh yeah oh this is okay yep yep
okay
uh these two clowns are giving the
schultz a bad name
there are no victims in this family
circle oh this is somebody in the family
this is a different person shame on my
aunt and uncle oh this must be the
sister
shame on my aunt and uncle for allowing
both their adult
cousin yeah well the sister of the other
guy is what i'm saying
uh yeah cousin right my aunt still
working on my uh
sorry shame on my aunt and uncle for
allowing both of these adult sons to
continue to live under their roof
my aunt still works and my uncle was the
mr mama in the family
there's four children sherman is the
oldest then there's addie a high school
teacher
and married now she's also been in the
videos with three children she was
pregnant with her twin sons
then there's earl and dale who live in
seattle
graduated graduated ohio state and now
uh
i know we moved away from the craziness
uh
that household dale's very successful
though
um earl has painted some beautiful
paintings in his day
doubt but he has he's very weird though
he used to dress up as a pirate like
johnny depp and did you buy jesus
no the you know what i thought you meant
was the other email from charles schultz
not
not this family is all over the place
man
uh he used to dress up as johnny depp
and pirates of the caribbean as far as
sherman
he scammed family members out of a lot
of money in the past the other brother
maybe that's why he lives with mommy and
daddy now i love my aunt and uncle but
it's hard to feel bad for anyone
in this household but i do feel bad for
my cousin addie
who lives across the street from the
chaos but uh i don't know if i expose my
children to their
uncle and creepy uncle sherman i hope
there are no guns in the house my oldest
brother had a substance addiction about
10 years ago
my parents wouldn't let him live with
them so he was homeless for maybe five
years he's sort of straightened up
still an [ __ ] though homelessness was
a life lesson for him though he was
trying to get his [ __ ] together now i
can't stand them but i
do see him trying i think earl needs to
be committed and sherman needs to be
thrown out on his own and allow my aunt
and uncle to enjoy their retirement
years tough love i say
i've commented on earl videos before
letting him know what a piece of
[ __ ] he is i'd appreciate it if you
don't mention my name which i didn't
uh if you share this information but i
realize you all curious about the family
dynamic and the branch of the family
tree thank you so much
we are learning you know it's bad when
you pull up when you pull up a family
thing and other family members are like
no guys you guys are right hold on you
don't even know the worst part oh yeah
oh
yeah so he used to dress up like pirates
of the be of the caribbean
he's dressed like johnny depp yeah which
is
honestly like you got a figure right
figure you got a son right
and he starts doing that kind of [ __ ]
when he's young imagine
how much do i uppercut him imagine
seeing that and thinking he's not going
to get any weirder than this though
yeah god this is just a weird face he's
going through and he's going to
he's going to blossom into a great young
man with a great future and then you're
like oh my god i actually missed the
johnny depp cosplay
can we go can we go back to that can we
go back to when you were larping as a
pirate
yeah that was way better yeah i loved
pirates as a kid too but get a [ __ ]
grip on yourself
stuff unusual which means that he
doesn't like people on drag
he doesn't like people who are
cross-dressers
the general sense he does not like them
and he
beats them and that includes me he beats
me and he puts me in the hospital
and the rest of my family are too
religiously inclined
to really consider support wow he's out
of his mind
he is out of his mind in this video
for me in this situation now you
consider me the problem instead of him
you are the problem never done anything
to this man in my life
he just beats me i'm the
problem for all of them and i'm putting
this on video to talk about it
five years on of it happening you're 32
you shouldn't be living with them at 32
years
old you absolutely selfish prick and
then screaming at your dad to take your
secret scenery
reach and tell me you owe me a hundred
dollars even though you don't pay rent
and you ran up three grand on his credit
card yep
it's like yeah this guy's and the guy
said i'm just on social security what do
you want me to do
it's been five years of beatdowns
it's been five years of me talking about
it which is difficult because i get beat
down
for that nobody
hits you but trust me trust me
earl everybody wants to
everyone you talk to wants to hit you
and it's not even because of the drag
queen stuff or the thing it's because
you are a terrible human being and you
deserve it you deserve it
[ __ ] man these these [ __ ] this these
people are messed up
here's what's wrong with society boiled
down to a person
he is society